I'm Paula Prentiss
I'm Richard Benjamin to the Census
Bureau we're known as mr. and mrs.
Richard Benjamin to women's lib we're
known as Paula Prentiss and her friend
oh really
the nominations for documentaries short
subjects are the gifts Robert McBride
producer interviews with me live
veterans Joseph strict producer a long
way from nowhere
Bob aller producer machine Vivian and
Patrick Kerry producers time is running
out Horst Delmar and Robert manago's
producers the winner is interviews with
me live veterans Joseph's trick that's
his trick we'll accept the award for
producing Joseph's trick
thank you the nominations are the best
achievement and production of
documentary features are Chariots of the
Gods
dr. Harold Reinold producer Jack Johnson
Jim Jacobs producer King a film record
Montgomery to Memphis Eli Landau
producer say goodbye David H valper do
sir
Woodstock Bob Maurice producer and the
winner is Woodstock
on behalf of Michael Wadley and all of
the many many people who contributed
their energies and talents to the making
of this film
thank you for the great honor